welcome to the fascinating world of
artificial Journal intelligence AGI
where machine possesses humanlike
cognitive abilities imagine a future
where computer understand information
and learn reason and adapt like humans
picture this a super smart computer that
can do all kind of thing on its own from
solving problems to being creative
imagine a car that not only drives
itself but also makes decision like a
human driver in tricky situations AGI is
like bringing a new level of brain power
to machines this exciting Tech could
change everything improving medicine
improving our learning and much more so
get ready for a future where AGI
transform the way we live the work and
making our world more Innovative and
more exciting so hello everyone my name
is mang and welcome to this fantastic
video on artificial Journal intelligence
by simply learn in this video we will
cover what artificial general
intelligence is after that we will delve
into what a AI can do what are the
Technologies driving AGI research and
what's the difference between artificial
intelligence and artificial general
intelligence and at the end we will
cover some example of AGI and future
scope so just a quick info for you
before moving on to what artificial
general intelligence is if you want to
switch career with AI and ml by learning
from the experts then try giving simply
learn postgraduate program in a ml from
P University in collaboration with IBM
this course teaches in demand skills
such as machine learning deep learning
NLP computer vision reinforcement
learning generative AI prompt
engineering chat GPT and many more so
don't forget to check out the course
link from the description box below and
the pin comment so without any further
Ado let's get started what is artificial
general intelligences artificial general
intelligence AGI represent a branch of
theoretical AI exploration aiming to
develop software exhibiting humanik
intelligence and self- learning
capabilities the goal is to enable the
software to undertake task Beyond its
specific training or initial development
existing AI operates within fixed limits
for instance AI for image task can't
create website AGI seeks to create
autonomous AI with self-awareness learn
new skills and solve problems AI is
mirroring human abilities is a
theoretical goal in AI research so
moving forward let's discuss what can
artificial general intelligence do
artificial general intelligence AGI has
the potential to do wide range of tasks
just like humans it can learn new things
on its own understand complex problems
and adapt to different situation for
example it could help with various jobs
from driving cars to cooking and even
creative tasks like writing or painting
AI might make our lives Easier by
handling everyday challenges and finding
solution to our problems however it's
important to note that AI is a still
theoretical concept and we are working
towards making machines that is smart in
the future so moving forward let's
discuss what are the Technologies
driving artificial general intelligence
research so creating artificial general
intelligence AGI is a challenging goal
for researchers but emerging
Technologies fuel ongoing efforts so
let's take a look at some key areas the
first one is deep learning deep learning
teaches computers to understand complex
pattern from raw data like text audio
and images it's handy for creating smart
system for example Amazon sales maker
helps developers build simple deep
learning models for things like The
Internet of Things iot the second one is
generative AI generative AI is a subset
of deep learning lets machine produce
realistic content based on what they
have learned AI models from companies
like AI 21 labs and meta can handle
complex tasks and tools like Amazon
betrock make it easy to deploy these
models on the cloud the third one is NLP
natural language processing NLP allows
computers to understand and generate
human language Amazon legs for instance
helps organization build chat boards for
easy conversation the fourth one is
computer vision computer vision lets
system understand analyze visual data
it's used in self-driving cars and for
the tasks like image recognition Amazon
recognition automates image analysis for
various
application the fifth one is robotics
robotics involves building mechanical
system that can perform physical tasks
in AGI robotics brings machine
intelligence into the physical world AWS
Robo maker helps simulate and test
robotic systems before putting them
together for example a robotic arm with
AGI could learn to sense grasp and peel
or enges like a human so these
Technologies contribute to the journey
toward AGI bringing us closer to
creating intelligent machine Ma and with
diverse abilities so moving forward
let's discuss what are the differences
between artificial intelligence and
artificial general intelligence so over
the years AI researchers have achieved
big milestone making machine smart
enough to mimic human-like intelligence
especially in a specific task take AI
summarizers for instance using machine
learning to pull out important
information from the document and create
easy to understand summaries so AI is
like a computer science Magic that help
software tackle the jobs almost as well
as humans now here is the exciting part
agis goes even further it can solve
problems in many areas just like a human
all by itself without anyone telling it
what to do unlike regular AI which is
good at specific things AI is like a
superhero that learns on its own and
solves problem it was not trained for it
is like the dream of having a complete
super smart computer brain so some
computer experts think AI is like a
hypothetical computer program with
humanik smarts regular AI needs lots of
training for specific task while AGI
could grasp things like a human without
special training for instance to make a
big language
model understand medical stuff you would
have to teach it with a medical data AI
could just get it without extra lessons
let discuss future Trends and
examples so predicting a specific future
Trends in artificial general
intelligence is challenging but we can
anticipate some general direction based
on ongoing research and advancement in
the field so here are some potential
Trends and examples first one is broader
application domains so future AGI could
extend its capabilities to diverse
domains beyond the current scope of
specialized AI example include Advanced
problem solving in science engineering
and creativity where machines can
contribute no all ideas and the
solutions so the second one is
autonomous learning and adaption AGI
system will likely become more
autonomous continuously learning and
adapting a to new information without
explicit programming for example an AGI
based virtual assistant might learn to
understand and respond to user
preference and task over time improving
its performance without manual
intervention so the third one is ethical
and responsible AI as AJ evolves
addressing ethical concern and and
ensuring responsible AI becomes crucial
future Trends may include the
development of Frameworks and the
regulation to guide the ethical use of
AI preventing biases and ensuring
fairness in decision making
processes the fourth one is human
machine
collaboration AGI could facilitate
seamless collaboration between humans
and machines for instance in healthcare
AI might analyze vast amounts of medical
data to assist doctors in diagnosing
complex diseases leading to more
accurate and timely treatments the fifth
one is natural language understanding
and the generation so AGI May achieve
remarkable progress in natural language
understanding and generation this could
lead to Advanced language models that
comprehend human communication nuances
and generate content with creativity and
coherence so it's important to note that
AGI is still largely theoretical and
realizing these TS depends on overcoming
significant technical ethical and safety
challenges so the development and the
deployment of AGI will likely to be
grateful process marked by iterative
advancement and continual
refinement so with this we have come to
end of this video if you have any
question related to artificial general
intelligence please feel free to ask in
the comment section below our team of
experts will reach out to you as soon as
possible so thank you and keep learning
staying at ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here